hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
dortmund heute gibt endlich mal wieder
eine folge nachgemacht original trifft
sally ich hab schon ganz ganz viele
anfragen von euch bekommen ich habe auch
mal auf instagram eine umfrage gemacht
was soll ich als nächstes nach machen
und ganz oft kam toffifee es kam jetzt
örtchen ist kam medica tender es kam
irgendwie ganz viele verschiedene sachen
und heute habe ich mich dazu
entschlossen meine jetzt örtchen
nachzumachen
ich habe mich jetzt für die ästchen
entschieden denn oft ist es ja so in den
originalen jetzt örtchen steckt er zum
beispiel alkohol drin das heißt kinder
und muslime und leute die einfach kein
alkohol konsumieren können das ja gar
nicht essen
deswegen machen heute jetzt örtchen an
als alkoholfrei wer will kann aber
natürlich auch angeboten so fügen und
ich zeige euch einfach mal eingesetzt
hat sind wie es von innen aussieht und
dann werden wird einfach ganz schnell
selber nachmachen die gatter früh eine
zeit sein oder früher gab es die dann
gab es eine zeit lang nicht mehr
und jetzt gibt es die wieder und
eigentlich auch mit die immer gern
gegessen
und irgendwann stand der x man hat nicht
mehr geht also die sind ja immer so
hübsch verpackt in diesem schiffchen
sieht aus wie ein schiff und überzogen
bitterschokolade und dekoriert mit
vollmilchschokolade und wenn man sie
öffnet euch jetzt schneiden soll aus
fehlt auch so hat man hier im innern
zweimal eine kalkschicht also einen
kakao bizkit und eine creme
und so werde ich das jetzt auch machen
ich mache so einem ganz lockeren whisky
wird für den teig und mache eine leckere
schoko buttercreme ich mich richtig
lecker und ich werde es er zuerst mit
der schoko mit dem schoko biscuit
starten und zeige ich einfach mal kurz
die zutaten
ich habe hier zwei eier dies sind auf
zimmertemperatur bereit
aufgewärmt hier habe ich 100 gramm
zucker ich brauche eine prise salz ein
bisschen von meinem mann in schotten
extrakt für den geschmack hier habe ich
mail und zwar 40 gramm eineinhalb
teelöffel backpulver hier habe ich 20 g
speisestärke und 30 gramm kakaopulver 50
gramm mineralwasser und 40 gramm butter
und zwei sie schon zu lassen und
abgekühlt und viele fragen mich immer
mit was ich sie teelöffel unsere ab
messe weil wir immer als immer so viel
aussieht und zwar habe ich hier einfach
meinem es laufen und da kann ich immer
ganz genau eben das abmessen und habe
immer die gleiche menge und ich hätte
das ganze hier gleich in meinem bett
krabbeln packen
den habe ich schon eingestellt und zwar
möchte ich auch von der größe her was
die kästchen genauso groß sind wie das
original
und zwar ist das original 8,5 x 3
zentimeter groß und ich habe jetzt den
bug rahmen eingestellt auf etwa 34 mal
30 genau und kann das später einfach
zurecht schneiden
jetzt stelle ich nur ganz normalen
bizkit her und nehmen zuerst die eier
und geht's mir in meiner küchenmaschine
könnte aber natürlich auch im handwerk
gerät machen
der zucker kommt auch direkt mit dazu
und auch die prise salz hat so ein
bisschen
und die vanille gebe ich auch mit rein
da brauche ich jetzt auch nur ein paar
tropfen weil es sehr konzentriert ist
und das wird jetzt so etwa fünf bis
sieben minuten lang richtig cremig
gerührt bis es weiß schaumig ist
und jetzt vermisse ich meine backpulver
mit dem mehl damit nicht clubs und gibt
dann gleich die trockenen zutaten mit
rein aber zuerst und jetzt zu dieser
mischung also ästhetisch ist richtig
schön weiß cremig aber eben nicht so
ganz steigt wie in einem normalen
biscuit zuerst gebe ich da jetzt noch
das wasser mit rein und las desto
niedriger stufe unterrühren
dann brauche ich auch die küchenmaschine
nicht mehr den rest hab ich nämlich dann
mit dem teig sauber und jetzt kann es
hier direkt die trockenen zutaten mit
rein geben also auch kakao speisestärke
und mehr aktive und es lebe ich jetzt
damit eben keine klumpen gibt
hab dann cacau ist es immer ganz wichtig
und das habe ich jetzt mit zu einem
schneebesen unter sich übrigens ein
flacher teller wesen
aber es geht auch ein ganz normaler
schneebesen
und dann kommt gleich noch die flüssige
butter mit rein weiß halt wichtig dass
sie echt nicht mehr heiß ist weil
ansonsten das eigengewächs
so und jetzt kann ich den teig schon um
viel
eben meine vorbereitete backform einfach
ihr ein date auch schön flüssig das
heißt kann reduziert teil
und jetzt kommt der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für etwas sieben bis neun
minuten in den backofen
ich werde nach sieben minuten bereits
die stäbchen problemen zahnstocher
machen
länger wird daran mich gebacken also
sobald er durch minister ihn rausnehmen
damit er einfach nicht austrocknen und
dann lasse ich wenig abkühlen und der
zwischenzeit bereiten wir schon mal
zusammen die buttercreme vor
mein tag ist bereits gebacken ich hab
mir die im hintergrund stehen zum
abkühlen habe ihn vor abgedeckt damit er
nicht austrocknet und hier stehen jetzt
schon die zutaten für die buttercreme
und zwar habe ich hier 160 gramm mild
wieder eine prise salz wieder ein
bisschen vanille shoppen extrakt hier
habe ich 50 gramm schokolade und zwar
ist es tat bitter kuvertüre ihr könnt
aber normale schokolade nehmen 30 gramm
zucker 1 eigelb 15 gramm stärke und
später brauche ich dann mit 100 gramm
butter ds zimmer war aber die kommt
jetzt nicht mit in den pudding deswegen
stelle ich sie mal zur seite
zuerst gebe ich jetzt die milch in den
topf und werden einfach mal die
schokolade bisschen klein hacken sie
muss sich nämlich gleich in der milch
auflösen
minute ganz normale tafel schokolade hat
könnte es einfach in die feinen
tröpfchen einteilen um das reiche müssen
seine taten dann nehme ich mir hier die
stärke die verrückte täschchen bisschen
mit der milch damit es nicht so klumpp
einfach professionell hier wieder zurück
hast du zwei esslöffel
und dass frühe ich hier gibt auf das
eigelb mit rein sorgt nämlich auch für
die bindung und dann kommt die
schokolade schon mit so milch und es
lasse ich dann bei niedriger stufe so
ein bisschen auflösen und sobald die
schokolade gleich aufgelöst hat geben
einfach alles andere dazu
also ihr seht die schoko - die kocht
jetzt auch nicht ich gebe da jetzt die
prise salz mit rein und bisschen vanille
finde ich kommt immer ganz gut und auf
den zucker dann kann sich ein bissl
auflösen und jetzt gebe ich an der
stelle schon mal die eigene stärke -
mischung mit rein
damit das auch schön auflöst kann man
übrigens alles auch komplett in der
kendrick machen also wenn jemand eine
kennwort hat könnte das ganz einfach
darin machen und zwar durch ein fachbüro
gefallen und jetzt werde ich das bei
mittlerer stufe erhitzen bis eben im
pudding entstanden ist dann müsste halt
jemand dabei rühren damit nichts
anbrennt
und sobald der pudding dann eingedeckt
ist so wie hier kabinett auch nur einmal
aufkochen lassen das reicht auf jeden
fall schon werde ich ihn um damit
einfach schneller abkühlt und muss ihn
dann abdecken damit er nicht so eine
haut bildet bei uns ist draußen tat
ziemlich kalt ich kann deswegen auf die
terrasse rausstellen
ansonsten will ich ihn einfach bei
zimmertemperatur stehen lassen in den
kühlschrank wörtchen ins netz stellen
weil wir noch ganz heiß und einfach
direkt mit frischhaltefolie über
abdecken direkt auf den pudding kleben
damit sich diese haut jetzt einfach
nicht bildet jetzt muss ich so etwa eine
halbe stunde warten bis der pudding auf
zimmertemperatur abgekühlt ist wie
gesagt man rechts draußen und dann
kümmert gleich um free erst heutigen
zusammensetzen
ein kuchenteig ist abgekühlt meine
schokocreme es auch schon abgekühlt also
auf zimmertemperatur wird kann ich meine
buttercreme fertigstellen
dafür nehme ich mir jetzt einfach die
zimmer warme butter und gebe sie hier in
der küchenmaschine geht wie gesagt auch
wieder mit dem handrührgerät ganz normal
und die muss ich jetzt so ein paar
minuten etwa fünf minuten lang weiß
cremig rühren damit sie einfach schön
locker wird und in der zeit werde ich
schon mal den pudding durch ein sieb
streichen damit der einfach weil der hat
ja vielleicht park lämpchen betritt das
mache ich jetzt muss ich nicht noch eine
dritte schüssel nehmen gebe ich jetzt
einfach da rein und streicht den wunsch
jetzt gebe ich ja nach demnach einfach
den schoko pudding mit dazu und lass es
cremig verrühren
und dann ist die schoko buttercreme auch
schon fertig sie riecht auch richtig
lecker und man weiß hat einfach was
drinsteckt
ich nehme da übrigens immer ganz gern
zartbitterschokolade ihr könnt zwar auch
vollmilch nehmen aber ich finde dann
wird einfach die creme viel zu süß und
zu wenig schokolade deswegen den ich
ganz bitter weil er einfach der
kakaoanteil höher und der zuckeranteil
eben bisher geringer ist das kann ich
jetzt hier kurz stehen lassen und habe
jetzt hier meine meinen teil und zwar
ist er jetzt 41 34 cm breit und 30 cm
lang
jetzt habe ich mir das hier schon ein
bisschen markiert und zwar werde ich den
jetzt einmal halbieren
das heißt dann ist ja hier 17 mal 30
und auf die eine hälfte 30 jetzt die
schokocreme gleich drauf aber ich möchte
im boden jetzt erst noch trinken
jetzt könnt ihr entweder so wie bei mir
zum beispiel so eine haselnuss milch
nehmen die gibt in grösseren
supermärkten also ich hab jetzt bei
globus gekauft in der veganen abteilung
im kühlregal
da gibt's haselnuss nicht da gibt's
mandelmilch sojamehl familie und so
weiter
und das ist ziemlich gut ist natürlich
auch laktosefreie weins vegan ist und
hat einfach so diesen haselnuss
geschmack ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel einfach ein bisschen baileys
nehmen oder einen anderen likör oder zum
beispiel im café nehmen also egal mit
was ihr das tränken wollt nehmt einfach
irgendein flüssigkeit damit es einfach
so bisserl saftig bleibt
und jetzt nämlich einfach den pinsel und
trat damit diese milch aus hat so ein
bisschen verletzt sondern nur ein
bisschen feucht werden
das mache ich jetzt erstmal nur auf der
unteren hälfte
alkohol wird übrigens weise
fertigprodukten auch immer verwendet
damit eben konservierter totale fertige
backwaren eben länger frisch und
deswegen steckt es oftmals in zu
fertigen sachen mit drin war ich ganz
kurz bis eingezogen ist und dann gehe
ich gleich die buttercreme drauf
zum verstreichen nehme ich mir einfach
eine winkel palette könnte eine kleine
oder eine große benutzen
und wenn ihr euch hier so eine tankkarte
trans stellt so wie hier habt ihr auch
vorne zum abschluss und kommt einfach
auch bis zum rand
und wenn ihr das dann so ziemlich
gleichmäßig habt also sollte halt
gleichmäßig dick sein
kommt halt einfach die zweite schicht
traum musste vorsichtig erst oben
ansetzen dann unter und ich nehme dann
noch eine zweite zum zweiten toppen
retter und drückt es kurz an einfach
damit eben platt wird so geht aber zum
beispiel auch ein schneidebrett falls
ihr keinen zweiten retter habt streicher
außen sieht knaps
und bevor ich das jetzt klein schneiden
kann ihnen die einzelnen teile muss ich
noch mal kühl stellen
das mache ich so etwas jetzt 15 minuten
im gefrierfach oder einfach eine halbe
stunde im kühlfach hasen küchen
ich kenne jetzt meine jetzt örtchen
schneiden ich habe sie übrigens auch an
der oberfläche noch mal getränkt mit der
kasse genommen und jetzt schneide ich
sicher einmal links durch also ich habe
das gemacht bevor ich ins gefrierfach
gestellt habt einfach damit eben auf
einziehen kann
dann habe ich jetzt vier jeweils
achteinhalb zentimeter in der breite und
jetzt schneidet sie einfach 3 cm breit
das muss ich mir das hat auch ab und
dann stelle ich sie aber noch mal kühl
und werden derzeit schon mal meine
schokolade vorbereiten
meine jetzt ihren sind jetzt schön kalt
und sie schmecken auch so schon richtig
gut das heißt weiß ich jetzt die arbeit
mit dem coup mit der kuvertüre sparen
will kann sie auch so lassen sondern es
auch schon gegessen aber ich habe es
natürlich auch schon kuvertüre
vorbereitet und zwar brauche ich jetzt
so überziehen einmal zar peter gruber
türe da habe ich jetzt 400 gramm und
einmal vollmilchpulver türe da habe ich
jetzt etwa 100 gramm geschmolzen und ich
hab das jetzt schon vorbereiteten hat
meine kuvertüre einmal hier in zum
tempel gerät geschmolzen einfach damit
ich jetzt die ganze platte wärme drauf
habt aber ich habe auch hier in meiner
kenwood da hinten die zweite kuvertüre
geschmolzen das heißt weil es zum
beispiel eine kennwort hat kann es
einfach darin machen denn da bleibt ja
auch ständig war und wer gar keine
maschine hat macht einfach mit dem
wasserbad ganz normal am herd und achtet
einfach immer darauf dass die kuvertüre
schön warm bleibt und dann können dass
sie eben super verarbeitet so ich nehme
meine kalten jetzt örtchen dann klappt's
auch richtig gut also wenn die richtig
kalt sind und schmeißt es jetzt einfach
hier in die kriterien und bedeckte
komplett mit der ouvertüre am besten mit
zwei gabeln dann wird es hier raus
geholt und ich blocke es dann einfach so
parallel ab
damit ist eben auch noch durch bist
und wichtig ist halt wirklich dass die
kuvertüre temperiert wurde also auf etwa
30 grad damit sie halt keinen schleier
kriegt ihr könnt übrigens auch in einem
anderen video bei mir rein schauen da
habe ich auch schon auf zur türe
temperiert sowie bei dem bauern dies
habe ich das mal gemacht und wenn euch
die kuvertüre aber zu fest ist könnte
hier noch so wie sie ist den palmen
benutzen das ist ein reines kokosfett
und da geht man dann einfach so ein
kleines stückchen mit reihen haben auch
einen schönen klang und das ganze bleibt
eben schön flüssig habe ich mir der
profiteure überzogen und nehmen jetzt
meine volle möhre mit zum lasse hier
praktisch streifen drüber und dann könnt
ihr wenn ihr wollt das ganze mit
zahnstocher noch so längst durchziehen
das habe ich hier gemacht aber mit
welser so gut deswegen lasse ich das
jetzt einfach so kann man auch zu neuen
preise kommentieren es ist richtig gut
aus für hat recht
der dieb soll jetzt übrigens mache ich
diese nachgemacht reihe ja nicht um
jetzt zum beispiel die originalen
komplett zu ersetzen oder um das ganze
günstiger herzustellen sondern es geht
mir echt darum dass man halt einfach
weiß wie so was eben nach gemacht wird
und was einfach drin steckt also welche
komponenten und oftmals ist halt so dass
jemand zum beispiel auch so was gar
nicht als so ein original gar nicht
essen kann weil zum beispiel allergenen
stoffe drin sind und dann finde ich es
ganz gut wenn man eben so was hat aber
es hat natürlich auch einen anderen
hintergrund und zwar hatte ich ja auch
schon mal nutella selber nachgemacht und
da habe ich euch ja mal erklärt wie viel
zucker und wie viel fett ebenso
fertigprodukten drinsteckt hatte ich
auch damals beim hinter schule gemacht
mit mein neues class lerin und am anfang
war es dann erste war wieso machen wir
die sind nach und nutella ist doch schon
lecker und alles aber am ende waren echt
alle doch so ziemlich erschrocken wie
viel zucker drin steckt und ich denke es
gibt schon einige die sagen okay ich
kaufe zwar vielleicht noch das original
aber ich mache auch manchmal selber
einfach so dieses bewusstsein
so sehen jetzt meine fertigen jetzt
örtchen aus also hier meine
nachgemachten uns jetzt im vergleich zum
original
natürlich sind meine eltern schöner weil
zu nehmen sie in pinkfarbenen papier
stecken ist klar und wir haben sie eben
schon probiert und sie sind wirklich
sehr feucht innen und auch sehr lecker
der einzige unterschied zwischen beiden
ist finde ich also meiner meinung nach
die normalen also die originalen jetzt
erzählt zimmer warm und kalt das heißt
beim e6 die creme etwas fester und die
jetzt örtchen krems etwas weicher weil
sie eben nicht abgestellt war und das
war mein rezept und ich würde mich
freuen wenn es nach macht gerne dürfte
mir noch weitere wünsche schreiben was
ihr euch als nächstes als nachgemacht
reihe wünscht toffifee steht auf jeden
fall bei mir mit auf dem plan
aber diese noch so ein bisschen
schwierig nach zu machen bzw
ich will es einfach perfekt machen und
deswegen könnt ihr euch gerne was
wünschen und mir gerne eure fotos wenn
ihr uns nach gemacht habt auf facebook
und ängste abschicken
ich freue mich schon wieder aufs nächste
mal und den block bericht gibt es auch
salehs - block b des dungeons